partenaire bonjour Patrick bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
sénateur du Nord président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat on est toujours avec
Pascal Jalabert qui représente
quotidienne régionale on l'a vu à
Marseille cette victoire de la Gauche
unie symbole peut-être du résultat des
socialistes mais si on va voir il y a eu
des divisions est-ce que ce matin vous
êtes un président de groupe heureux
Patrick canard en tout cas satisfait du
sur l'objectif que je m'étais fixé avec
mes collègues sénatrices et sénateur
socialiste à savoir rester le deuxième
groupe au Sénat le premier groupe de
gauche d'opposition donc au Parlement
Assemblée nationale comprise et puis une
satisfaction qui est à caractère
constitutionnel c'est que nous
conservons suffisamment de sièges pour
déposer à nous tout seul un recours
devant le Conseil constitutionnel et on
l'a vu que récemment cela avait été très
utile alors vous perdez néanmoins
quelques sièges vous êtes à 60 ans selon
la projection il ne faut pas il ne faut
pas le cacher c'est pas c'est pas la
droit qui les gagne c'est la gauche qui
les perd puisque là on perd des sièges
vous voyez on aurait pu gagner un siège
en Ardèche on aurait pu en gagner un
aussi dans les Deux-Sèvres on en perd
dans d'autres départements c'est
essentiellement par la division je vous
donne un exemple très concret Nelly
Tocqueville c'est la crise socialiste
des seine-maritimes perd à 5 voies son
siège son deuxième siège dans la liste
tirée par Didier Marie 5 voies et il y
avait dans cette élection bien sûr la
liste socialiste la liste communiste la
liste verte et la liste PRG voilà donc
l'exemple les tarithmétiques l'Union est
prolifique on le voit bien dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône on le voit bien aussi
dans le Rhône ou on le voit bien aussi
dans le Bas-Rhin ou je pense que
le sénateur vers gagne grâce à la pluie
des socialistes en deuxième position et
puis là on est divisé on perd et c'est
du perdant perdant j'insiste
c'est-à-dire que dans une concurrence
électorale on peut se dire on se
présente et on se présente pour gagner
mais là c'est perdant perdant c'est à
dire que les socialistes d'un siège mais
ceux qui nous ont fait concurrence
n'enguent pas pour autant
c'est un message à toute la gauche à
toute la gauche à savoir que l'Union
encore une fois est nécessaire et
finalement c'est la gauche qui perd
quand un socialiste perd ou une société
perd c'est la gauche qui peut ça veut
dire que pour les régionales et
départementales il faut faire des
accords dès le premier tour dans les
régions dans les départements et à la
Cour nationale peut-être pour se
répartir les têtes de liste bien sûr il
faut il faut tendre à cela notamment
dans les départementales ou les binômes
qui existent aujourd'hui dans les
cantons permettent justement d'avoir une
diversification sur un territoire donné
sur les régionales ce sera plus
compliqué on le sait bien parce que la
symbolique de la tête de liste dans des
grandes régions est extrêmement
importante mais il faut tendre à cela et
j'espère que cette élection sénatoriale
qui a de très bons aspects la création
d'un groupe vert en partie je le dis je
dis bien qu'en partie grâce à cette
union dans lesquelles dans laquelle les
socialistes qui ont été extrêmement
dynamique constitue une réponse réelle
sachant tirer les enseignements positifs
et aussi parfois malheureusement négatif
de cette élection territoriale mais
restons Sénats vous parlez de la
création de ce groupe vert a priori une
douzaine de sénateurs est-ce que pour
vous c'est une bonne ou mauvaise
nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est
la traduction du évolution et je vous
rappelle quand même que les verbes
avaient un groupe sous le quinquennat
précédent qui a disparu en 2017 donc
c'est simplement le le retour vers une
situation que normale et
je dirais traduisant dans les
sénatoriales les bons scores dans les
grandes cités qui ont été gagnées par
les Verts et souvent même très souvent
aussi lié à l'Union mais vous parlez
justement puisque vous revenez toujours
à l'Union est-ce que vous actez la
création d'un groupe écologiste
indépendant ou est-ce que vous dites il
faut qu'on discute pour un grand groupe
de gauche commun
la gauche sort finalement renforcée
globalement au Sénat avec ces trois
groupes je pense que la sensibilité que
représente aujourd'hui repokologie les
Verts et d'autres partenaires de ce
grand parti politique aujourd'hui il
faut le dire tel quel mérite d'être
représenté est-ce qu'elle était la
responsabilité qui sera la nôtre demain
entre Parti communiste le groupe CRCE le
groupe socialiste républicain et le
groupe des verres je ne sais pas comment
il s'appellera exactement à ce stade
c'est de travailler ensemble pour que la
voix de la gauche qui représentera
finalement une centaine de
parlementaires puissent être entendus
ici au Sénat et au niveau national
justement au Sénat c'est facile parce
qu'il y a les communistes les vers les
socialistes et puis quelques radicaux de
gauche mais au niveau national jusqu'où
situez-vous la gauche que vous dites qui
doit finir pour les régions à
départementale est-ce qu'il y a Monsieur
Mélenchon dedans ou pas à Monsieur
Mélenchon fait partie de la gauche ça
fait horreur de ma part c'est une gauche
voilà un caractère protestataire qui
une fois fait des exclusives et je le
vois bien dans ma région des Hauts de
France où le leader potentiel de LFI
pour les élections régionales monsieur
bernalicis député de Lille à dire
récemment dans La Voix du Nord Jean-Luc
vous connaissez bien il a dit mais moi
je m'adresse à tout le monde sauf au
socialistes c'est pas bon signe parce
que nous sommes de gauche nous sommes
dans l'opposition nous nous sommes un
parti de gouvernement et or il est hors
de question d'imaginer un seul instant
que l'on puisse gagner sans les sociétés
par les régionales personnellement je
l'ai dit je pense que je peux être utile
pour réparer l'anomalie démocratique de
décembre 2015 à quelle place nous le
verrons bien nous avons des instances
qui vont maintenant se réunir un appel à
candidature va être lancé début octobre
je serai candidat pour être non pas de
tête de liste mais pour être chef de fil
des socialistes peut-être qu'il y aura
d'autres socialistes et donc ce sont les
militants qui choisissent dans les 5
départements la même chose je suis
candidat pour être utile vous êtes
candidat pour être utile
à quel moment vous allez discuter vous
mettre d'accord et qui va tirer la liste
ça je vous conseille qu'à un moment
donné il faudra bien une seule personne
homme ou femme ça mais le fait que nous
ayons des personnages politiques qui ont
souvent une région nationale
permettez-moi de m'y mettre mais aussi
bien Bruxelles par définition mais vous
avez Damien carême pour les Verts qui
est aussi députés européen extrêmement
connu et reconnu donc tout cela montre
que toute la gauche réunie veut faire
cette élection une élection très
importante et c'est pour moi un signe
positif ah c'est vrai qu'après il faudra
bien se mettre d'accord sur et vous
discute d'abord discutez
avec vous et puis en plus je ne suis pas
encore désigné chef de fil donc je reste
à ma place de simplement de sénateurs
mais par contre si discussions il doit y
avoir elles devront d'aborder sur le
projet quel projet crédible alternatif à
la politique de droite menée par
Monsieur que j'avais Bertrand est un
président de droite qui n'a pas
d'opposition parce que l'opposition
Front national pour moi c'est pas une
opposition c'est une protestation
essentiellement il faut une opposition
et j'espère même peut-être une majorité
dans les hauts de France si la gauche
est capable de se réunir si la gauche se
était réunie en 2015
avait su se faire je dirais s'il y avait
une suite forcé le destin en étant réuni
elle aurait été devant Monsieur Bertrand
une histoire n'aurait été différente
justement on va faire un peu dernière
question sur régionale on va faire un
petit peu de politique fiction vous le
disiez en 2015 la gauche c'est retiré
puisqu'il y avait
Xavier Bertrand et le Front national à
l'époque qui était en bonne position
pour l'emporter la gauche s'est retirer
pour éviter l'élection du Front national
comment PACA est-ce que si la situation
se reproduit en mars prochain la gauche
se retira à nouveau vous dites cette
fois on se maintiendra quoi qu'il arrive
boule de cristal
est-ce que le Front national que
j'appelle toujours pour national ou
j'aurais remarqué
fera 40 % sans Madame Le Pen qui ne sera
pas candidate on m'a non monsieur Chenu
pour être candidat je crois que le Front
national sera moins
et que donc on retrouvera peut-être des
clivages plus classiques ça a été évoqué
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure y compris sur
votre plateau par
mon prédécesseur moi je considère
aujourd'hui
que il n'est pas possible que la gauche
soit écartée de responsabilité au sein
du conseil régional pendant 12 ans ce
n'est pas possible et donc à ce plateau
je vous dis que et bien la gauche doit
être présente il faut réparer l'anomalie
démocratique et donc vous avez pu
interpréter en creux mon propos quoi
qu'il arrive vous
justement on vient de parler
du milieu il y a aujourd'hui la
République en marche qui a toujours
voulu cassé ce clivage elle s'en est pas
trop mal sorti de ces régionales on lui
prédisait le pire
un sénatorial pardon oui il y a des
régionales on verra voilà c'est un
torial comment vous positionnez par
rapport à ce groupe parce que vous
pouvez discuter avec eux ou alors vous
êtes dans leur position c'est là on
discute avec tout le monde et il y a
parfois des textes sur lesquels on se
retrouve avec la reine ou qu'on combat
face à la reine ça dépend des situations
on est capable vous voyez sur la PMA
nous étions à leurs côtés et
heureusement d'ailleurs que la gauche
était là pour faire passer la PMA au
Sénat en première lecture mais par
contre on est opposé à l'arène quand
elle propose le texte a dit
l'immigration donc nous ne sommes pas
dans une opposition systématique voilà
nous ne sommes pas une position
contestataire nous nous opposons et nous
construisons des réponses qui peuvent
être parfois communes
la partie gouvernement on sait très bien
qu'il y a l'idéal à atteindre et puis la
réalité de la vie quotidienne politique
qui fait qu'il faut savoir passer des
compromis sans être dans la
compromission à partir de de la reine
aujourd'hui a pris un sillon c'est le
sillon de la droite de la droite
libérale et d'ailleurs j'ai envie de
dire quand on a Édouard Philippe pendant
3 ans au gouvernement et maintenant
monsieur Castex pendant 2 ans et j'étais
nouvel ordre sont pas des hommes de
gauche ça serait et même s'il y a
quelques personnages
issus de la gauche qui sont perdus les
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui y compris
avec le ministère de l'intérieur c'est
la droite qui est au pouvoir et Monsieur
Macron ne s'en cache pas et d'ailleurs
il va braconner permettez-moi
l'expression y compris maintenant de
grands élus de droite et je pense à
Christian Estrosi qui clairement a fait
des offres de services pour le prochain
quinquennat donc les choses se
clarifient la vraie question qui se pose
quand vous dites les choses se
clarifient ça veut dire si on suit votre
raisonnement que la droite aujourd'hui
ne peut pas se revendiquer comme une
force d'opposition puisque le
gouvernement est à droite mais en tout
cas la droite aujourd'hui est braconnée
sur le plan des personnes et siphonner
sur le plan des par Monsieur Macron et
la droite n'a plus qu'un seul chantier
c'est la sécurité être hyper sécuritaire
un peu plus que le gouvernement sans
tomber dans le sillon là aussi de
l'extrême droite il reste plus grand
chose parce que la politique économique
et sociale du gouvernement je pense que
Monsieur Daillé pourrait la partager
d'ailleurs il la partage en grande
partie donc la droite aujourd'hui a très
peu d'espace alors que la gauche en a
retrouvé la gauche a été explosée au
début du quinquennat toujours par cette
logique du du braconnage et du
chiffonnage aujourd'hui nous retrouvons
des couleurs politiques de la clarté
politique et c'est tant mieux la droite
est dans une difficulté de position sur
les chiffriciers politiques français de
bien plus importante et donc la vraie
question c'est est-ce que Monsieur
Macron sera en 2022 ou non le candidat
de la droite mais ça faut poser la
question aux intéressés alors justement
le plan de relance arrive présenté par
le Gouvernement et la majorité
vous vous dites c'est une politique
libérale vous allez vous y opposer de
quelle façon alors déjà ce plan de
relance devra être intégré dans le mode
silence donc et nous aurons des
amendements le budget voilà pour être
plus clair pour nos téléspectateurs donc
nous aurons des propositions nous ferons
un contre budget avec Valérie rabot
comme le faisons depuis maintenant 3 ans
je crois que c'est sain de dire qu'il y
a une autre voie possible surtout
le social enfin je crois qu'il est clair
que pour nous nous allons devant une
catastrophe sociale et que donc
l'absence de mesure réelle pour pour la
jeunesse l'absence de mesure pour le
pouvoir d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat on dirait que c'est
un ça devient un gros mot mais il faut
les gilets jaunes là sont aujourd'hui en
déliquescence
j'ai envie de dire de présence sur le
terrain mais le malaise est toujours là
donc les classes moyennes inférieures
continuent à souffrir elles vont
souffrir encore plus demain les jeunes
vont se retrouver devant une vague de
chômage qui elle est submerger et donc
le social n'est pas assez représenté des
choses ont été faites sur l'écologie
manière pour moi résiduelle mais
aujourd'hui aucun effort n'est demandé
ni au chef d'entreprise qui vont
bénéficier encore de la baisse des
impôts de production ni au plus fortuné
de nos concitoyens qui ont bénéficié
depuis 3 ans des largesses du
gouvernement donc ça ce n'est pas
supportable s'il y a de la solidarité il
ne peut pas être réparti de manière
équivalente pour tout le monde il faut
de l'équité et l'équité c'est faire
payer peut-être un peu plus en cette
période de crise ceux qui ont dans les
moyens Patrick canard vous avez annoncé
vouloir vous représenter à la présidence
de votre groupe vous savez déjà si vous
aurez des concurrents ou si vous êtes le
seul candidat le secrétaire général du
groupe socialiste des républicains lance
ce matin même l'appel à candidature
l'élection aura lieu demain matin à 10h
je serai candidat à ma succession s'il y
a d'autres candidats j'ai envie de dire
que la démocratie je n'ai pas encore
entendu parler que la démocratie passe
vous nous dites vous vous êtes le
premier groupe parlementaire de gauche
au Parlement vous nous dites la gauche a
un espace est-ce que votre mission à la
tête de ce groupe ça va être de montrer
que le Parti socialiste existe encore
c'est essentiel et que le Parti
socialiste n'est pas un parti en
déliquescence nous l'avons montré
municipale nous le confirmons de fait
aux élections sénatoriales
parce que aujourd'hui c'est 30 à 40 000
militants ça fait rendre ma part je n'ai
pas les derniers chiffres que possède
Olivier Faure je vais vous montrer que
nous voulions nous rassembler vous savez
j'étais à Blois pendant quatre jours
j'ai vu 2500 militants et sympathisants
socialiste non les valeurs que nous
représentons existent ce qui est certain
c'est que la vraie question et ce sera
le débat du Congrès que nous aurons en
décembre à Villeurbanne c'est est-ce que
nous devons peut-être faire évoluer la
page du grand parti d'Épinay est-ce
qu'il y a des évolutions pour intégrer
peut-être d'autres préoccupations que
nous n'avions pas à Épinay la
préoccupation peut-être d'une république
forte c'est quoi la laïcité aujourd'hui
c'est quoi le service public aujourd'hui
dans notre pays au travers de la
République et aussi bien sûr la
transition écologique donc nous avons
encore du chemin nous avons une
existence de plus de 100 ans vous le
savez aujourd'hui et bien nous ne sommes
pas morts et nous allons le démontrer
Olivier fort à sa tête c'est lui que
vous soutenez à la tête du PS pour ce
problème
nous verrons bien s'il y aura s'il y
aura d'autres d'autres motions moi je
soutiens
[Musique]
je souhaite que nous ayons par exemple
un candidat aux élections
présidentielles et que voilà le parti
son premier secrétaire l'ensemble des
élus doivent tout faire pour y parvenir
et il n'y a pas de fatalité à ce qu'il
n'y a pas de candidat aux élections
présidentielles
c'est une question est-ce que c'est une
première interne une première externe en
tout cas
on est venu là-dessus depuis le début de
notre entretien je suis convaincu que si
aux élections présidentielles il y a un
candidat et les filles candidat
socialiste un candidat vert monsieur
Macron
boulevard de la grande tranquillité
devant lui